what we're going to do in this video is
explore the sampling distribution for a
difference in sample means and we'll use
this example right over here so it tells
us a large bakery makes thousands of
cupcakes daily in two shifts
shift a and shift b
suppose that on average cupcakes from
shift a
weigh 130 grams with a standard
deviation of 4 grams for shift b the
mean and standard deviation are 125
grams and 3 grams respectively
assume independence between shifts every
day the bakery takes a simple random
sample of 40 cupcakes from each shift
they calculate the mean weight for each
sample
then look at the difference a minus b
between the sample means
find the probability that the mean
weights from the samples are more than
six grams apart from each other so i'm
actually not going to tell you
immediately to pause this video and try
to work through this on your own first
i'm going to think about how we could
break this down and then i'll ask you to
pause and try to tackle each of those
parts by itself
so in order to tackle this eventual
question we're going to have to think
about the mean of the sampling
distribution for the difference in
sample means
so sample mean from group a minus sample
mean for group b
we're going to have to think about the
standard deviation of the sampling
distribution for the difference in
sample
means
and we're going to think about is this
distribution normal
if we're able to figure out these three
things then we just have to figure out
well how many standard deviations away
from the mean is this and we could use
your standard z table to figure out the
probability
so now i encourage you to pause this
video and try to tackle this first part
what is the mean of the sampling
distribution for the difference in
sample means
all right now let's work through this
together so the mean of the sampling
distribution for the difference
in sample means and we have seen this
before this is going to be equal to
the difference between the means of the
sampling distribution for each of the
sample means so that mean minus this
mean
and we also know that the mean of the
sampling distribution for each of these
sample means that's just going to be the
mean of the population that we are
sampling from so this mean right over
here is just going to be the mean the
population mean for shift a which is
going to be 130 grams
i'll just write that there
and then the mean of the sampling
distribution for the sample means from
shift b we can see that that's just
going to be the population mean for
shift b which is right over here
so minus 125 grams and of course this is
just going to be equal to
5 grams so we have answered the first
part we know the mean of the sampling
distribution of the difference in sample
means now what about the standard
deviation so for that let's think
actually about variances because the
math's a little bit easier with
variances and then from that we can
derive standard deviations
so we know that the variance
of the sampling distribution for the
difference in sample means assuming that
your two samples are independent and
you're sampling with replacement if
you're sampling with replacement it's
actually going to be the sum of the
variances of the sampling distribution
for each of the sample means so it's
going to be that plus
this
right over here
now you might be saying wait we're not
sampling with replacement
well we also know that if each of the
sample sizes are less than 10 percent of
the population
then the difference is negligible and so
we could still use this formula and so
you could see that the simple random
sample here is 40 from each shift and
they say that a large bakery makes
thousands of cupcakes daily in two
shifts so even if it was a thousand ten
percent of that would be a hundred this
is less than ten percent so we meet that
condition so we can use the same formula
that you would use if you were sampling
with replacement so this first variance
right over here of the sampling
distribution for the sample means from
shift a this is going to be equal to
the variance of shift a the population
variance of shift a divided by your
sample size
and then
this over here is going to be the same
thing for shift b
it's going to be the variance
of shift b
divided by your sample size and so this
is going to be equal to what
well the variance from shift a is going
to be the square of the standard
deviation from shift a the standard
deviation's right over there and so
that's going to be 16
we could write grams squared if we want
to keep the units there and then we're
going to divide by the sample size we
know that the sample size in each case
40 cupcakes
at a time for each sample and then for
shift b
we know
that the standard deviation the
population standard deviation for shift
b is 3 grams you square that and you get
9
grams squared a gram squared is kind of
an interesting idea but that's what the
units are working out to be right now
and our sample size is still equal to
40. and so this is going to be equal to
let's see 16 plus 9 is 25 common
denominator of 40. so it's 25 over 40
which is the same thing as 5 8
5
8
of a gram squared which is a little bit
strange units but this now tells us what
the standard deviation is going to
because it's just going to be the square
root of all of this business so the
standard deviation of the sampling
distribution for the difference in
sample means over here
is going to be the square root
of 5 8 and now of course the units are
back to grams which makes sense and this
is approximately going to be equal to
get my calculator out 5 divided by 8
equals and then we take the square root
of that
and it's going to be approximately 0.79
0.79
so the next question before we try to
figure out the probability is is are we
dealing with a normal distribution here
when we think about the sampling
distribution for the difference in
sample means
and so i encourage you to pause the
video again and think about that so
there's two ways that we can assume that
the sampling distribution for the
difference in sampling means is normal
if the original populations that each of
the sample means are being calculated
from are normal then that means that the
sampling distribution for each of the
sample means is going to be normal and
that means that the difference of the
sampling distributions are going to be
normal now we don't know for a fact that
the weights of the cupcakes from each
shift are normal distributions but we
also know that the sampling distribution
of the sampling means can be modeled as
being approximately normal if the two
sample sizes are greater than or equal
to 30 and we know that each of these
samples are definitely greater than or
equal to 30 they are 40. so that tells
us that the sampling distribution of the
difference in sample means is also
normal so we've established the things
that we need to then calculate the
probability so i encourage you pause the
video and see if you can use that
information to calculate that
probability and we will then do that in
the next video